hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video und zwar
wurden die ultra häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben joker zog
normalien die regime you later das ist
das was ihr gott eingeblendet sehen wir
sind das mädchen dann rechts auf der
seite und wir stehen auf einem typen und
versuchen andere mädchen auszuschalten
die auch auf diesen typ bestehen
ich glaube das war eine ganz gute
zusammenfassung das ist echt so dass
mais gewünschte game was ihr irgendwie
bei mir haben wollte sehen klicke ich
einfach mal auf new game und ich
versuche ist konform acht länder easy
lover of female die sorry das feature is
what was ihr müsst wissen das ganze so
eine betaversion wenn ich jetzt jede
rücke ok mail
ich bin auf den typen stehe ich jetzt
und den machen wir richtig shokof haben
mir wird oft gesagt luca denn nur das
spielzeugs dann mach mal bitte dass es
nicht so kommt schwarzer hautfarbe gelbe
haare geht das überhaupt oben hängt
dieses der hassliebe ihn mir wird gesagt
luca wenn du das ganze game zockst dann
schneide bitte nicht so viel weil man
darf da nicht so viel von wegnehmen weil
man sehr viel irgendwie auch ich habe
keine ahnung wie gezockt aber mir wurde
gesagt ich soll nicht so ich habe die
nachricht bekommen deswegen versuche ich
gleich wenn wir im game sind einfach
nicht so viel zu kalten also ich drücke
findet okay solange wie sie sich
erinnern kann war sie noch nie mehr
kombis kippten die ganze scheiße hier
einfach mal
kann ich als ok wenn ich das gerade
richtig interpretiere hätten wir gerade
mit einem mädchen die gesehen hat dass
wir auf diesen typen stehen und sie hat
den typen aber mit einem anderen mädchen
gesehen und dieser name von meiner
mädchen des osama al kini the crush on
him also sie ist dies das ist das könnte
jetzt vielleicht kommen wir jetzt gibt
das ganze mal es ist montag der dritte
april und wir können konnten und wir
sind jetzt vielleicht auch mal wir sind
ingame das hier ist unser bett dass sie
es unsere spiele konsole
das ist unser computer wo wir unsere
let's play aufnehmen das ist meine
bandkollegen man die schule
wahrscheinlich sagen jetzt viele ich
auch lokalmatadorin urteil gesetzen
nicht eh nicht so viel sagen kann sein
dass wir ultra riesig sind oder sind sie
einfach viel größer als der eingang the
world
dass unser crash ich liebe dich hey
vorlage mit migros allawi please sagt
mein dicker samt inhalt wir können hier
tatsächlich nehmen konnte nicht
rumlaufen
okay aber das steht so ein cooler
hyundai ich weiß viele schreiben jetzt
wahrscheinlich lukat bekanntesten nicht
ja ich bin aber immer noch in diesem
cutting den dingen drin
ich kann das ist wirklich so richtig
katja seit 12 jahren gaming videos und
bei mir ist es so ich kann jetzt quasi
das ich habe wie so rotzig in offenen
mikro mann ist beim kommentieren schon
da drin dass man kann also man macht
absichtlich pausen und so war warum
stehen die dahin alle vor ihrem fucking
schränken und interagieren damit gar
nicht immer einfach
eine ewigkeit später ja das war ein sehr
interessantes gespräch gerade ich kann
die tatsächlich mit jedem trocken ich
möchte aber eigentlich nur zu meiner
großen liebe und ihm sagen deine haare
sich nach scheiße ich stehe auf scheiße
es wird also wie kann man solche haare
haben und was wirst du dazu ich verstehe
das spiel nicht in der chemie leder so
nice sorgt das doch mal bitte ja super
spiel auf jeden fall ich denke wo laufen
alle wohsmann muss meine große liebe
rosa hin ausgerichtet es rausgerissen
rausgenommen da ist nach vorne rücken
der wies mich sind
ich hab verloren
wie kann ich damit sie so schnell
verlieren ich mach mal laut check point
und was guckt er so dumpf bestimmte lady
die irgendwas zu sagen hat hier oder
nicht
wahrscheinlich
da ist eine schöne trillerpfeife schaut
mal wer da vorne ist vielleicht kreuzen
sich ergangen zufällig unsere wege
freunde hier liegen waffen wir können
glaube ich oh mein gott
das spiel scheint sehr brutal zu sein
ich werde aber an dieser stelle das
ganze spiel einfach mal beenden meine
damen und herren das war mein erster
teil von andy rihs simulator wenn es
euch gefallen aber ich meine bewertung
von ich habe das wirklich vor noch nie
gezockt wie bei irgendwem mir wirklich
so richtig angeschaut ich hab nur
gelesen es geht darum mann ist ein
medien und steht auf den typen und
anderen mädels stehen auch auf den typen
und man muss die an der mädels
ausschalten und ich habe jetzt gerade
schwerter gefunden und kann jetzt
wahrscheinlich kämpfen deswegen wenn ihr
im zweiten teil haben wollt und tipps
für dieses pocking spiel habt schreibt
mir das alles und in die kommentare wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder rein
tschüss ich liebe euch ich habe euch
ganz toll